Mì buồn tháng 3, thu tường Pakistan, Ong Sieva Sharif, công bố thành lập lực lượng tên lượng lực quan tải
thú đối sữa là mặt, chỉ muốn ngay trước khi kỳ nhận ngày đầu bập lần thứ bàm biệt tán của nước này.
Lực lượng vũ trong mời đưa trong bị công nghệ hiện đại và có bộ chi vĩ dân, chuyên sử li và trên khai
tên lượng trong mọi tình của trên tranh thông thường. Theo Ong Sriep, lực lượng mời có khả năng tầm công từ mọi hướng
và là bức tiền quan trọng trong việc tăng gượng năng lực tắc trên tên lượng của Pakistan. Lượng
mời tập trung quan bộ năng lực tên lượng của cộn nội, giới chỉ một đau mỗi chi vĩ, thay vì được quản lý giải giáp trong các sư đoàn
vào bình, phó k vị nhỏ như trước, điếu này dút Pakistan trên khai tên lượng nhàng hơn, phố hợp
hiệu quả hơn trong trên hợp dù đồ. Các chuyên gia quân sự nhận định, đúng thái này là nhằm đối trọng là như
lấy sau khi, đổ và các khíc tăng đúng phát gạo trang hội tháng 5 và qua, khiến tại mặc dù lận yên bản đã được thi lập,
nhưng mất đầm có đỏ ai xung quan của podcast via trang chấp, vẫn chưa được phó giải khiến viết cơ bùng phá suốt có thể sảy ra, mất kỳ lực nào.